i wish the local news
i i'd very rarely watch local news but
when you do watch it it's very
depressing so-and-so was murdered today
yeah so-and-so
it's just story after story and i get it
like these are
and they sensationalize horrible things
but like uh
on uh
i'd never watch it but i remember there
was a robin mean she does she's the girl
that she's like the face of cnn
headliner not cnn
yeah she always does like
the the you know morning sunshine like
the good story of the day like
heartwarming stories
need more of those yeah we need more
more mr whitman it needs to be
highlighted the thing is this stuff is
happening it's just not a moneymaker
exactly it's not a headline grabber
that's not going to make people mad and
fired up and then you know
sometimes it's not about being mad it's
about being grateful you know you know
you know what the challenge is i think
here's what the challenge is so we know
what what weekend this is it's the
weekend that gets skipped it's father's
day weekend right father's day doesn't
get it gets 1 100 of the recognition
that mother's day does for many reasons
but it's father's day right
so
what what's what's what's the one thing
we like we want recognition now
we want results now
we want to be told that the little
conversation we have with our son we see
the you know residual effects of it when
now we want to go to the gym and see the
six-pack now we want to go out there and
read a marriage book and our marriage
gets fixed now we want to go buy a
mutual fund or a stock or bitcoin and we
want to become rich now right everything
is now
but but sometimes you have to know that
that little value you taught to your son
or your daughter you're probably not
going to see the positive effects of it
for 30 40 years and you have to be okay
with that sometimes when you go buy that
mutual fund or the stock and you're
trying to be a millionaire tomorrow
you're probably not going to see the
results of it for 10 or 20 years it's
okay be patient sometimes when you go
start a podcast and you're by yourself
nobody is there and you hear 20 people
like i remember we would do something
like 13 people oh [ __ ] we got 13 people
i wonder who these 13 people are
definitely not my relatives definitely
not to be i'm okay to all the 13 people
out there thank you for listening right
and then you realize later on 2 3 5 10
20 years later there is impact right so
so we have to
understand and be a long term thinking
to know that the positive impact
a person is making a great teacher i say
great teacher because there's there's
the ones that go above and beyond great
leaders great parents great mothers
great fathers those that take this stuff
seriously you're rarely going to be
rewarded for the great job you're doing
today you're not gonna get rewarded for
a decade or two and that's okay
because when the recognition is given
the impact is a thousand times more than
you would have gotten instantly so just
be patient don't expect to do good i've
had a guy that was working with me
years ago i really believed in this guy
a lot
uh but he was overly uh negative overly
uh arrogant
and everybody had a hard time working
with this guy this was a sales office i
was running like in 2004 2005 insurance
i was sitting down i'm like listen man
listen do you realize
you've had so many jobs the last 10
years
and you sit in front of me and when it's
just you and i all you talk about is how
all your bosses were bad okay
you have to understand maybe one boss
i'll buy maybe two boss i'll buy but if
you tell me eight bosses were bad i have
a problem with that and you have to be
aware of this that it's not the world
you're extremely capable you're
extremely talented
you have a heart inside somebody in your
family ruined you a little bit what
words they said or they made your life
easier your damn your mommy mom babied
you and you're just a little pansy now a
little bit someone needs to tell you
but if you can depensify yourself
and toughen up a little bit i think one
day you can truly make a massive impact
in your life this is a late night
conversation that we had he'll remember
this
so what happens six months later he
leaves okay and now i'm the enemy i'm
the new boss
guys
so he's trashing me behind closed doors
and you know this
i'm like dude i'm so patient i said dude
i'm gonna get that phone call
what happens five years later i get that
phone call he's the president of a bank
a hundred employees
report to him and work with him he's
making killer money he calls me says you
have no idea how hard it is to make this
call and how much i've been looking
forward to making this call i said tell
me why
i said you know of course i know who you
are i've spent a lot of time we ran a
lot of appointments together he says do
you know what i'm doing right now i said
i have no clue he says i'm officially
the president of such and such bank he
sends me the details i don't want to
disclose it he's making multi-six
figures he's killing i got a wife got
kids he says pat no one in my life
talked to me the way you talked to me
that day my own family wouldn't
challenge me the way you challenged me
but i've been reliving that conversation
the last five years and i finally
realized it is on me it was my fault it
wasn't my boss's fault and i took
responsibility look in my life now those
are my favorite phone calls and by the
way i am so patient because i receive
those calls all the time maybe not in a
year maybe not two maybe not three maybe
not five maybe not ten but you're going
to get that cause because eventually we
realize
the only way you can change your life is
what
through you
the only way things change is through
taking personal responsibility that's
the only way things change so you know
to those that sometimes we are so
conditioned social media to point you
mate we want the likes now we want the
shares now we want the views now
yeah relax yeah future looks bright you
know who has a lot of conversations like
that dads
dads
dads my dad sits me down you know you
you brought up father's day i just want
to say like shout out to all the dads
dads are so important
i mean in my house my dad i would sit
down with my dad
my husband always jokes with me and he
says i love you because you have so much
self-respect and you know my dating
history we'll probably get into this at
some point on your show but my dating
history was like i don't put all the
goods out there you know i'm not like
that i'm very selective those
conversations the reason i'm the way
that i am came from conversations i had
with my dad powerful my dad taught me
like you need to respect yourself or
they won't this is how you need to be
treated by a man this is how a man
treats you this is how a boy treats you
know the difference those conversations
happen with my dad conversations about
discipline and school everyone who
everyone here knows you probably already
figured out i have no patience it's not
a good trait my dad is always on the
phone like be patient it's a virtue you
must learn patience i'm working at it
but those those important conversations
yes i'm close with my mom you know we're
like a girls club my mom and i she's my
best friend but don't underestimate the
power of a dad and it just reminded me i
know you're a dad i know you love your
kids so much but that what you just did
is something that dads do so well and
it's so important to have those kinds of
conversations to be straight with your
kids shout out to the dads it just
reminded me of my dad and how he talks
to me sometimes you need that reality
again yeah and my dad does it in a very
different way for my mom my mom and i
can kind of be like did you see yes i
did and she agrees with me and we're
like but my dad sometimes is like hold
up you know this is and and he really
made me into someone people say when
people say to me you're a badass i'm
like thanks dad every time every time so
shout out to dad's tony tony he's
listening
respect but by the way you know how they
say anyone can be a dad but not everyone
can be a father yeah
father figures is is super important or
a father lee figure is so important and
by the way you know i gave jedediah like
a slow clap earlier i want to give you a
clip i don't know
i'm
but what you said is is so freaking
powerful pat because it kind of goes
back to my point where we're arguing but
it's like look you can go every excuse
no oh the president of the politics it's
like you gotta look in the mirror and
you gotta take some accountability for
yourself so if you like this clip and
you wanna watch another one click right
here and if you wanna watch the entire
podcast click right here